bien es un gran desafío ya que el país
ahora mismo está sumido en la
recuperación es lo más importante para
ellos sí es cierto que ya se ha
prometido la construcción de miles de
viviendas para los más desfavorecidos y
un plan para la reducción de pobreza
infantil
estos son planes que se han quedado en
el tintero debido a la situación a la
situación de crisis pero bueno es algo
que tendrá que enfrentar porque son
promesas que han proclamado por otro
lado para los próximos cinco años ha
prometido que el cien por cien de las
energías que va a emplear al país sean
energías totalmente renovables así como
que en un periodo de aquí a 2025 todos
los plásticos difíciles de reciclar
serán retirados del uso y del mercado
entonces se enfrentan es en este momento
a ese tipo de respuestas